one of the main reasons for wanting to
make the film was my dad's writing so
one of the things he was doing you know
after receiving this news like within 24
hours he started writing this whole
history of his marriage to my mom and
looking at his life and his relationship
and I totally candid way in which he
hadn't before and it was he instantly
sharing it with you yeah and I think
that's what made me that's what made me
feel like for me that was the most
interesting story was this person who
could have responded to this news with
so much anger and betrayal and a sense
of disappointment or blame instead
responded with this kind of
transformation and wanting to look at
himself and his relationship in a
completely different way and wanting to
share that and he became so much more
open sort of emotionally and in every
way and so for me that was what was most
interesting to make a film about so he
is writing began right away and then I
had asked Terry to write his you know
version of events and I was going to
write mine and I had you know at one
point I had this fantasy we'd all
published something together which no
one was interested in except me and and
then that became sort of the fact that
we were all telling these stories I
think became from Harry seemed to be
quite acquisitive about his story and
publishing his story was that an actual
sense that this had to be stopped on
your part my feelings are what are in
the film or that I I felt like this
story that didn't include everyone's
point of view and the impact it had on
everybody for me wouldn't have felt fair
in some way so I felt like you know my
in a way my dad is the person most
impacted by this story and for it to be
just told as this you know kind of happy
reunion story between a biological
father and a daughter would omit you
know this huge transformation in his
life and also you know a very
complicated set of feelings and in my
life and so that felt like I I would
have been uncomfortable if that was the
you know first way it was told although
you know their aspects
that story that are that are true and
that you know deserve to be out there
and I sort of tried to include them in
in the context of the film as much as
possible so I think that his story is
completely legitimate and he has the
right to tell whatever story you know he
wants but I I felt very passionately and
I was lucky that Harry was really
respectful of this and participated in
this version I just felt that the first
version i wanted to be very inclusive of
everyone's point of view and not leave
anyone out um just before we locked
picture I let everybody watch it alone
and I just wanted to know if they had
any issues or things that they felt
uncomfortable with or things they were
upset about and I just wanted to know
that before we locked picture and
strangely i think everybody like nobody
had any comments I know that Harry had
some notes and some of those we
addressed and others we didn't but in my
immediate family everybody everybody
kind of signed off on it even though
it's not the story they might have told
I think there was nothing that upset
anybody which was a huge relief I feel
like we're closer I mean we were we
robbed we've always been close but I
feel like um it's been a really amazing
experience to get to hear strangers
responses to such personal stories it's
been a really interesting experience I
don't think any of us are particularly
you know people who expose our private
lives all the time and so like this is a
it's it's it's an interesting experience
because it doesn't feel like we're too
exposed or too vulnerable but it feels
like people kind of know what there is
to know about our family and that's
that's been really interesting I've
generally been a bigger fan of
documentaries than I am of fictional
narrative film so for me it was really
terrifying to make my own documentary
and so I think I'm probably more
influenced by the documentaries I've
seen then by the work I've done in
fiction myself mm-hmm which
documentaries of Plato influence to you
in particular i'm not sure if they've
directly influenced this film but um you
know Alan King was probably my favorite
documentary filmmaker I love the five
obstructions by lars von trier which you
know really did inspire me to a certain
point halfway through working on this
film i saw that film and it made me feel
that at least i wasn't grappling and
dark I think one of the most intriguing
elements to me is your role in this
documentary not just as master director
and interrogator but your actual role in
the film being seen in the film was that
a difficult decision for you about when
to include yourself yeah it was really
hard because I probably didn't want to
be in it at all and I think that what I
realized is my role in the film was the
person discovering all this and and as
the daughter but also has the filmmaker
and so to include that in the film was a
big decision to include me constructing
the film was a big decision and it
wasn't wasn't necessarily an easy one to
make